[Music]
foreign
be sure to pee before we go this
adventure is going to be a long haul and
I don't feel like emptying The Jug while
the pee will return momentarily it in
The Jug are ultimately red herrings that
exist only to set up a rather unfunny
centipede who eats urine joke later so
you're getting two Saints Rick and Morty
for pissing all over my valuable time I
made your Atomic Matrix slightly lighter
than air and now your shoe shoes are
heavier than air which makes you
neutrally buoyant which I find
personally more impressive conceptually
than walking on water but what do I know
I wasn't born into the god business I
guess Rick's proclamations on his
godliness make this decision and the
resulting hijinks the product of his
hubris but that won't stop me from
pointing out that Rick's magic does
whatever the plot needs pistol probably
could and should have been able to make
Jerry neutrally buoyant without his
shoes but you think the centipede wants
to eat your pee since matter can be
neither created nor destroyed I have to
ask where does the pee go when it's
inside the centipede I mean even if it
evaporated or something that still seems
Less Pleasant than just peeing in The
Jug you've written out of the story for
some reason you young people think space
is like Saturday Night Live you see it
every day so you dream of being in it so
then it's nothing like Saturday Night
Live because it's not on every day and
I'm pretty sure whichever generation is
currently being accused of lacking work
ethic has never seen it literally
everything is out here and unlike
everywhere else I'm too busy to help you
never mind the fact that he does end up
helping Morty after he gets bitten by
the space snake I'm more concerned that
the writers think changing a space Tire
requires more concentration than
toppling a Galactic Federation seducing
a hive mind or fixing a fragmented
space-time which you coincidentally also
broke Morty's starting to look like a
90s Japanese ghost I'm not gonna send
Rick trying to flex his knowledge of
ringu but I'm more than willing to call
him out for not knowing that Juan The
Grudge came out in the odds imagine
being a racist snake hey other snake I
hate you because you're the wrong color
snake I had a hearty laugh when I
realized how easy it is to replace the
word snake in this statement with the
word human then I cried because frankly
it's sad that a lot of humans have yet
to learn such a simple lesson but then I
laughed again because conceptually a
racist snake is just funny then I I
cried again because conceptually a
racist human is not funny so take your
sin back so we can get back to laughing
but also this snake parade is traveling
in a straight line spitting right in the
face of the slithering snake aesthetic
that has abandoned aerodynamic
efficiency for the sake of these wobbly
snake Rockets I I can't be the reason
why 19 billion snakes lost all hope
using Morty's guilt is a reason for him
to do some questionable things with a
snake sure is a weird way to get the
story rolling especially when you
consider how many people he killed in
episode 1 of this season and how little
he cared about the hope he robbed from
those families I don't know which Red
soda this is but without naming names I
drank one of them several years ago
after walking five miles in the hot
Texas sun and then proceeded to vomit
furiously never been able to forget the
uniquely potent flavors of its Ingress
and subsequent egress and the sight of
red fluids has continued to haunt my
Waking Life so as far as I'm concerned
they're all a sin Morty not being smart
enough to know that when this snake
sheds the temporary tattoos will likely
go with it is slightly less concerning
than the overt speciesism he displays I
think thinking one snake could be so
easily replaced with another I mean like
me showing up at your Thanksgiving
dinner with a matching Team Edward
tattoo and acting like I didn't regret
getting it your family would see right
through it everyone has a
writers think they can milk this plumbus
every time they need a quick laugh
this snake is somehow now wearing the
space snake suit properly even though
earlier Morty was shoving it into the
suit face first if it doesn't work for
sleeping bags it shouldn't work for this
the next two minutes of this show will
be Supercuts of snakes doing the same
things humans do with these same things
humans would use to do them because it's
funny to anthropomorphize animals
especially when it makes no sense
evolutionarily but unfortunately the
funniness of the SS
doesn't negate the sininess of the logic
[Music]
to be fair newscasts involving humans
are no more interesting than this
downbeat how do you
work Rick spending time with his
grandkids in a scenario that doesn't
involve putting their lives at risk
makes me question everything about this
scene like is this a simulation I mean
are they a simulation not am I a
simulation I am 100 certain that I am
real sure you pause Beth with a device
Christopher Walken gave me after a
record session taking the long way
around saying remote just so you can
make a reference to an Adam Sandler
vehicle from the mid-2000s thinking this
is a better name for a bar than Devil's
protuberance of the mammary gland upon
which the lactiferous Ducks open and
milk is drawn just rolls off the tongue
right one Diet Sprite remix please and
uh is anyone here an Uber driver Jerry
the obvious pool table light not being
over the actual pool table and frankly
your bar has a lot of sailing things
Jerry brings up an interesting point
here that honestly isn't addressed
enough in this world when you over
ceiling fan your bar you're just asking
for trouble whether it's a man who
brings in a boulder one day because he
claims he will float without it or it's
Davey having one too many shots at
Tito's and then deciding to see how many
pool cues he can jam in all the fans bad
things will will happen things you'll
never be able to unsee just say no to
over ceiling Fanning you will thank us
summer house suits shook in my eye by
your playlisting fleekness tonight
trainers thought my cheeky ass would be
high he is stressed by the vibe but
Summer's Squad is just being extra and
that's super sus so bye Felicia I think
my little brother got bit by a snake in
outer space and killed it with a hubcap
can you alter the course of a species
Evolution like that without repercussion
saying the more he altered the course
makes it sound like there was a
predetermined destination when what
happened was more akin to an
unintentional participation in their
evolution I'd say an encounter with a
new species that results in death is
very much in line with the principles of
natural selection in this case the snake
literally bit off more than it could
chew and as a result they were not
selected for the next round of the
tournament
Beth was right there watching the creepy
snake man's Judgment Day sales pitch
aliens I am a robot sent back in time by
the snake resistance to protect you from
surfacorp so her reaction here is more
comedic than logic dick Rick pulp
fictioning Morty back to life in the
middle of Crossfire from time traveling
snakes seems much harder than helping
Morty deal with one snake while changing
a tire but for reasons Rick seems much
less angered here than he was during the
cold open the war between snakes and
machines snakeration 2 Judgment snake
how exactly were they able to get a
picture of Morty even if the snake was
able to describe how he looked this
attention to detail is insane I know
we've gone over this so many times but
you can't just write the present and
expect us to know what that means does
that mean 2019 present because that's
not the [ __ ] present for me get
behind me your brood will seat all life
on this planet that doesn't make sense I
don't care if it doesn't make any sense
the deceitful way that Morty brought
this earth snake to snake earth makes
the seeding of a planet more problematic
than the weird sacrifice at the
beginning of Prometheus I can't get
reception at my dentist but Jerry can
make a phone call thousands of feet in
the air Cherry almost never hits his
Target outside of the bedroom so this
working is just as much [ __ ] as
Jerry not being immediately killed by
the impact also the depth of this pocket
and and this phone not falling out of it
I don't suppose you guys will take a
bribe attempting to bribe a snake
officer of the law
the results of this literal and drastic
intervention in the biology of snake
kind don't play a bigger role in the
snake evolution of this episode it's
just 1985 but with snakes you know kind
of like 1952 with meerkats but not so
much like 1976 with possums that one was
a disaster also show wants me to believe
that Massachusetts is a phase that all
pre-warp civilizations must go through
that book has everything they need to
create snake time travel and they're
getting it in 1985 snake time the
existence of this book tells me that the
writers are aware that I'm aware that
they're aware that I'm a world
what was that
Oh [ __ ] forgot I left narrator bot
running how long did I leave this thing
on wow he should have been watching a
lot of Rick and Morty looks like he was
right in the middle of sinning I guess I
shouldn't leave this episode unfinished
well let me see where he's okay what was
he trying when he was sitting here look
I I don't know I don't know what he was
doing here I'm just gonna go with
something about some convenient 1980s
time travel [ __ ] cliche snake or ham
Lincoln survives this not that I wanted
snager am Lincoln to not survive this
but why is snake Lincoln so ready to
accept time travel that immediately
reads this note instead of being more
concerned about what just happened to
the well-dressed man from the 80s snake
Hitler not using a shower curtain but
mostly just being a snake Hitler just
have to keep my grip Jerry says as he's
holding on to the outside of a plane
likely traveling at something around 600
miles per hour craters if you're gonna
do this kind of we're eventually gonna
need a Jerry as an immortal super being
episode to explain it if that ever
happens we promise we'll give this sin
back
since British Airways once flew a 747
from LA to the UK on three engines now
I'm going to say that Jerry causing what
I imagine to be the first ever snake
Strike should have been a cause for
concern yes but not nearly the
catastrophic event that the show wants
me to believe it was also no matter how
many times I watch this I continue to
see a rocket-powered alligator that
suffered the loss of two legs and not a
rocket-powered snake that has suffered
the growth of two arms
ammonium out there Morty being a snake
demonius his soul somehow during all
this hacking and slashing Summer's
clothes stay clean how is the blood
physics of this scene just as silly as
Kill Bill but in the opposite direction
nobody
choked me without consent summer would
be 50 Shades of great at TV sins also
that's about as much curvature as you're
going to get from a time travel story
Josh futterman has entered the chat I
have fun snowing those snake costumes
together you little [ __ ] wait did Morty
say snowing instead of sewing Cindy run
that one back again I have fun snowing
okay one more time a little bit slower
Christmas episodes
everything they need to create snake
time travel and and they're getting it
in 1985 snake time the existence of this
book tells me that the writers are aware
that I'm aware that they're aware that
I'm a worm
yes in this video I revealed that I
built a robot to do the sitting for
shows I'd rather Skip and this silly
attempt at retconning my powers in the
cineverse was definitely a one-off gag
that will never ever happen again
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
but what do I know I wasn't born into
the god business I am God I'm dying Rick
I think I'm dying here man my Father's
Day
can you recognize the sound of a man's
pants filling up with rain I find your
lack of faith disturbing Merry Christmas
[ __ ]
I'm in a glass case of emotion
what the hell put that thing away now I
don't want to tell you again snakes time
travel I'm starving I couldn't hear you
over my own screaming we've talked about
this can you photoshop your life with
better decisions Jerry